and everybody can hear me is it okay
first of all
I would like to I would like to thank
the organizers for you know I think we
do this interesting event and I will
tell you about symbolic computing in
fightin with simple so what is symbol
it's library which has go to provide
facilities for symbolic manipulation of
expressions it's an open source library
and it here I write that it aims to
become what it already is the full
feature to computer algebra system and
things to fight working with fightin it
can keep the code I think as simple as
possible given the algorithms that it
implements and so thanks to using Python
its comprehensible and easily extensible
so a little bit about history of sci-fi
the development we'll start it in 2005
by my schoolmate we were both studying
physics and he started developing it in
2005 and in 2007 sin fight for the first
time was selected into google Summer of
Code and since that every year Google is
playing several students to develop
projects for sin pi which is I would say
very successful collaboration and in
2011 error mirror took over the link
develop front row
from Andre Katie and since then he is
the lead developer of Simba I have to
admit that I like started working on sin
pi in 2008 and since then I'm ATS in
recent years I'm not very active in
simply development but I'm trying to be
I have to speak with the current status
of of sin pi and current release in play
already has accumulated contributions
from more than 750 people and the
current code base is more than 500,000
lines so it has become a really big big
project so why would we like to use I
would anyone like to use limb by its
advantages is that its standard level
Python library its vs devices so it can
be quite easily incorporated into other
projects it embraces fighting is
fighting fire throws wordplay and it can
be used as user interface or as well as
a library so it can be easily included
in your projects but these points
explain why to you simply if you already
going to use some computer algebra
system but why would you like
as a data scientist and when I was
invited to this event I was I had no
idea what kind of people will be here
what are their interests so I cannot
answer this for you but I will give you
a few examples of what simply can do and
it's up to you to decide if it can be
helpful to you in in any way
I myself am a physicist so for me a simp
is useful for example for solving
differential equations calculating
derivatives integrals and so on but you
may have find different uses for it if
you want to like see what simba reuse is
used to then you can look at Google
Scholar list of citations of simple
papers or there is a superior group
collecting on scientific research
articles that were seen by us being used
I think some of this open here
yeah so for example here is some list so
you can get some inspiration of in which
fields sin pi is being used currently
but of course you may find new
applications here just for information a
list of other software projects which
are using simple internally for symbolic
computing I will not like go through
this list but they're just for
information and here is the current list
of simple features behind each of these
points
there are many pages maybe in tens of
pages of documentation currently the
documentation of syllabi contains about
two thousand pages and when I was like
choosing what what to show at this table
I had a hard time to select something
that is like a small subset that can be
shown in in 30 minutes or so so this
world this was a short introduction and
address for the most of the talk will be
in the form of interactive show in
Jupiter notebooks and let's start with
some raisins I don't know how many of
you have ever used some computer algebra
system maybe it will be the only one
questions it
have to please hands up people who have
ever used some computer algebra system
okay so it looks like half of you people
so you know you already know what I'm
talking about so if you I think
everybody knows the floating-point
numbers in the computers have limited
precision so when you do some
calculations like this you see that
parameters decisions affect the results
if you are using double double type you
have some 53 bits of accuracy which
means you can calculate it convert 53
binary 53 binary bits in two decimal
places and it's about 15 to 16 decimal
places and if you do repeatedly some
operations then in case that you're that
you for example don't care about your
algorithm too much it may be numerically
unstable and once you repeat some
operations several times for example in
this piece of code where the X should
basically always be equal to one but due
to loss of precision and to marry
instability just after some ten
iterations you all all the precision
offs
and now I'm sure how simple is symbolic
way so to start using simple you can
just import everything from simple and
the CANSIM by the numbers are
represented as objects which can be
either rational integer or float with
capital F and if I want to do the same
calculation like here I write it like
rational which is 101 over 100 minus 1
and I get the exact result because
simply is using symbolic computation so
everything is mathematically exact you
can input the expression in different
ways the program is that you can not
give sin pi if you write in Python 101
over 100 fighting automatically does the
division and it will either return float
or integer depending on python version
but you always lose precision if you
want to give this expression to sin pi
you can provide it as a string so sin pi
itself then parcel string then it always
also works with exact result or there is
this little trick there is an end
simplify function which basically takes
a float and converts it to a rational
number so it reverse engineers the
number and it also give you
exact result and if I rewrite the
algorithm that I showed you before or
recycle in within the simple numbers
during rationals you don't lose any
precision the results are always exactly
so few more notes about using simple as
a regular calculator with numbers it has
some predefined mathematical constant
like base of natural logarithm by
imaginary unit and when you type an
expression you may already see that
invitin when you type a mathematical
expression it gets evaluated but simple
data retains the structure of this
expression and in addition to this it
divide different defines very
mathematical functions and it knows
let's say most of the identity is
constraining these functions so when it
knows how to evaluate the function at a
certain point it will do it
if you want to know the numerical value
of an expression there is this function
n which evaluates the function with an
arbitrary precision here I asked for 30
decimal places and I get this expression
with accuracy up to 30 decimal places
the the library that does this
evaluation is empty mass it's the only
dependency of simple it's very fast
library for arbitrary precision
arithmetic I can easily ask for
thousandth decimal places of square root
of two and get it possible and now let's
get to symbolic computing the main idea
of symbolic computing is as the name
suggests that you are using some symbols
or variables in contrary to some other
computer algebra systems the symbols are
defined implicitly
where you just use it and it becomes
defined in it's imperative to create the
objects for this raise the function
symbols and you supply to it list of
names of the symbols and assign it to
variables it's good habit to name the
variables the same as the symbol names
you can do it differently but then no
one will
to understand the code and here I have
just a few examples you can for example
create such an expression and simply
just stores it doesn't do anything with
it it can do Latex printing within
jupiter notebooks you can enable it in
it printing function so then the
expression gets printed in a nice
mathematical notation and this is just
note how to create if you want to create
many symbols you can use such a notation
to create an array of symbols the basics
of using simple is just manipulating the
mathematical expressions that you supply
to it so for example you can create such
an expression and then there are many
functions to to manipulate it for
example you can expand for a polynomial
you did something like this this is easy
but you can also factorize this
polynomial which is the more difficult
question what simple can also do it and
then a variance for thing is that you
can do the substitution so for example
you can use the metal subs to substitute
this some X plus y with very opposite
this and it can also like the
manipulation with polynomials it can
collect for example when you have some
polynomial like this it collects the
tariffs with the same power of X if you
ask for it so you get let's say
second-order polynomial in X it can work
with rational functions so if you
provide some rational function to it it
can cancel it with one of us find the
common divisors and divide with them
it can also decompose rational functions
into partial fractions which is useful
for example for integration of
operational functions I will give you a
few examples what you can do the
trigonometric functions horizontal if
you take silence you can expand again
and nowadays this expand function I I
used it before the expansion of
polynomial but it can also expand
trigonometric functions if you give this
argument 3/2 and if you use the formulas
for expanding dragonology functions and
then simply also has a function for
simplifying using trigonometric form
yours and when you apply to this
expression you get again the input
expression
it knows the basic formulas like by this
for example square of sine and cosine he
goes wrong and many more now let's look
at exponentiation for example you can
write for my disks X to power of alpha x
right to alpha and you may think that
this can be simplified to x times y to
the power of alpha and to ask if the
power simplification can do it but it
doesn't simplify it and the reason is
that actually I did that it doesn't hold
in general it because simply assumes
that every symbol by default is a
complex number and for complex bases and
exponents this doesn't hold for example
this expression if you want minus 1 the
square root is I I times X minus 1 and
this is plus 1 so it's a counter example
and if you want to simplify this
expression you have to define the
symbols for example as posit the bases
is positive and the exponent is real
then this expression holds and the
simplification that we carry out
yet there is also the reverse function
to expand the simplified result and here
are just a few more examples that it can
understand nested exponentiation and for
example if you have a logarithm function
like this then you can again ask Simba
to expand the logarithm and you will
apply the formulas for logarithm of
multiplication or exponentiation and
again it is able to combine the
expression back to the original form
this need for assumptions that the
symbols are positive or real that I
showed here sometimes you just want to
avoid it you want to do some quick
calculation then these functions accept
the keyboard force it was true and then
you can force this for example expansion
even if it's not mathematically correct
for complex variables
regulation Chili's simply is also able
to rewrite functions for example it can
rewrite trigonometric functions in terms
of other trigonometric functions for
example you can ask for tongue and 6 in
terms of sine X or for example factorial
X in terms of gamma functions so here
I'm just touching a very broad topic of
special functions simply includes many
of their very complicated special
functions but I'm not not going to talk
about them it can also do combinatorics
you can rewrite binomial coefficient
using factorials or it can do the
simplification of binomials so sir just
really going through quickly through
many functions so so far it was just
manipulation of expressions
the next section may seem more
interesting and that's equation solving
that's something that we can encounter
quite frequently I have to make a remark
here about equality sin in Python and in
sin pi since sin pi is using Python as
its language and it doesn't attempt to
change the logic in any way it means
that equal sign means assignment and
double equal sign test for exact
identity of two expressions so it means
that if you print the expressions then
we the same then this double controller
which means to the expression is true
but if you want to define an equation
you need to define an object EQ like
this and you can solve it using the soft
subtraction and you get it attempts to
get all the solution of the equations so
in this case it's minus 1 or 1 it can
also solve equations with periodic
functions for example so here you can
see that I didn't provide an equation
but just an expression and then it
solves the roots of the expression which
means the source for the expression
equal to 0
thus offset also supports restricting
the solutions to a certain domain so we
can for example ask for real real
solutions of certain equation right here
and it will tell you that there are no
solutions in the real domain now thanks
to the assumption that all variables are
by default complex it will give you
quite many solutions even sometimes I
expect it like the exponential of X
minus 1 obviously the solution is x
equals 0 but also all multiples of 2i
pie in the complex plane
it can also solve any qualities all of
the capabilities are quite limited so
far and there are also functions for
solving systems of linear equations
it can also solve underdetermined
systems of linear equations like the one
here where I provide a list of
expressions I have two expressions which
are assumed equal to 0 and three
variables which means that it's hundred
inter mind so the solution is not a
unique set of numbers but it's a line
which is parameterized by these various
form that it can also solve systems of
nonlinear equations for example like
this so there are this four possible
doublet solutions now before going
further I will tell you a little bit
about the internals of simple how it
actually works under the hood so when
you multiply for example two symbols
each each of these symbols of course has
overloaded the multiplication operator
and let me do the multiplications it
returns multiplication objects with
which stores its arguments
so it basically there is a functions as
rapper which produces expression that
can be evaluated in sin pi to recreate
the expression and basically stores the
expression as a tree and we can create
such a function to print the three I
will not explain it in detail but this
one is simple but you can have some more
complicated expression like this one and
when you print the expression tree it
looks like this and we can see several
things in here for example this piece
for the expression that it's over Y is
here you can see that there is no
division what division is encoded as a
power of y 2 minus 1 similarly there is
no subtraction but it's if you want to
subtract X you had eggs multiplied by
minus 1 so this is just to reduce the
number of the objects in the equation of
the various classes of objects in the
expression tree and you can access the
elements of this object then you ask for
the fund you get the topmost part of the
tree and then you ask for arcs you get
they are the branches always and then
you can go deeper and ask for this
function and these arguments and so on
if you if you need it
so and now let's show something about
calculus which let's say for me is maybe
the most interesting part of simple in
general when you want to start simple
session you just import everything and
call in it session which creates some
disabled describe and you will see that
it creates some variables that you can
directly use and you don't have to
define everything so in calculus it can
calculate limits the limit function
takes expression limiting variable and
the point where to evaluate this
function is limited 1 0 then you
calculate the limit of one over x at 0
either infinity which may feel strange
because 1 over X does not have limit at
0 but the reason is that if you look at
the arguments of limit you see that
there is default direction plus so it by
default calculates the day the limit
from the positive side and then the
limit actually is infinity then
calculated from the negative side and
you get minus
and if you want to ask for the
bi-directional limit then you limit
let's say you can write the direction
plus minus and it will explain to you
that the limit does not exist now
something that is true for let's say
many objects or functions in calculus
you can either ask for evaluating the
limit with this function limit or you
can create an object code limit which is
not evaluated and you can evaluate it
later if you need it or you just use it
as it is now do the differentiation
there is again a function did you give
it an expression and the variable and it
will calculate derivatives you can do
multiple derivatives like second order
derivative if you provide the variable
two times or you can provide the
variable and integer which says how many
times you want to differentiate it with
respect to it so these two expressions
are equivalent you can differentiate it
with respect to multiple variables like
this and again similarly to the limit
you can also create an derivative object
which is not evaluated like this and
then you can use it for example to
define a differential equation
simp I can also do series expansion so
an expansion of exponential function
looks like this everybody but calculus
course recognizes it and of course you
can calculate series of more complicated
expressions and again if you look at the
arguments of this hump now you see that
the arguments are the variable in which
you want to do the series the point at
which you want to expand the series and
the degree and so for example here I
will do the series at one from the same
expression it gets much more complicated
because you lose the symmetry of
evaluating this at zero and I would like
to make night now we're short side note
and this if you want for example to get
an idea how rare this series corresponds
to the original expression you might
want to plot it so I show few examples
of plotting
again define the series
simple includes the functional plot
which you provide an expression and if
you do it just like this it will do some
adaptive sampling and plot the
expression in some default range you can
of course customize it and you can put
multiple expressions in in one plot so
this for example shows the comparison of
the function in blue and the series
approximation interact for example you
can also compare how increasing the
degree of the series improves the
agreement but I have to say that for
more complicated plots are I prefer to
use mark Portland which I'm used to work
with and it's really easy to connect set
by 2 ma totally you can use defy
function which takes an expression and
converts it to number function by
default
and you get this in my portlet you may
not this may be for example this small
thing that simple also allows you to
print index expression in high-tech so
then you can automatically create a nice
nice labels in the legend in
mathematically typed just to show you
what Lambda Phi does it actually defines
the function which looks the same like
the original expression but now this
expects in our new PI functions now just
quickly examples that you can also plot
3d surfaces or parametric surfaces and I
for convenience I'm using inline protein
but you can also use interactive
multiplet window there you can
manipulate with the 3d plot and this
yeah
so an important part of the calculus is
solving of ordinary differential
equations if you want to work with
functions you have to define the symbol
to be a function class and you can
differ in the equation like this and
solve it with a diesel function which
takes the equation and the unknown
function and you get a solution with the
integration constants
yeah I think I have to speed up so I
know now in order to show that surely
some working with the data I have a few
slides of some application of simple and
working with data
so let's generate some data we have here
- let's say time dependencies one is
decreasing in time the other is
increasing in time and let's say that we
have some model of this data we think
that the data are described by some
differential equation and we want to
find the parameters of this differential
equation let's say that it's some
equation a set of equations or this form
because we have two variables it
corresponds for example in chemical
kinetics - conversion of one species
into another so this orange ones are
being converted into the blue ones at
constant rate coefficient which is
encoded in such differential equations
and you can solve again this
differential equation but you can also
apply initial conditions to this
differential equations where you require
that the initial value of F 0 and 0 you
just name the variable like this in G 0
to be a neuron and you get a solution
like this and now if you want to find
these parameters you
generally you can do nonlinear least
squares fitting so you can convert these
functions into new PI functions and use
for example Allen fit or any other
fitting vibrator that you may want to
use and create a function which
calculates the residual which is
basically the difference between the
data and the model and call minimizer on
the residual it's very simply set and
you get these parameters and 0 and 1 and
alpha and if we now look at how we how I
defined it in the beginning point one
point one and one you seen it within the
errors which are also estimated here the
parameters are in agreement there's one
remark which for which simple can be
also useful for finding this optimal
parameters one has to calculate the
Jacobian of these dis expressions which
is the derivative of these expressions
with respect to each of the parameter
and in general there are F it calculates
it numerically which means that it has
to evaluate the expression many times at
some close spacing to estimate the
Jacobian but since you have seen fine
can calculate the derivatives
symbolically with the Jacobian function
which I could be inverted on matrix and
you convert this matrix into some
function which can be supplied to a LAN
effect
and again calculate least-squares do you
get the same result as expected that you
change but what has changed is
dysfunction evaluations now we have 12
function evaluations before we had 39 so
almost four times reduce the necessary
number of function evaluations if you
supply the Jacobian in symbolic form so
I think I should conclude now
I will conclude with a few remarks
Tauron cells also the my talk was of
course not meant to teach you how to use
sin pi but maybe to show you how how
easy it is to start using sin PI so I
recommend it to to try it yourself if
you encounter any problem
of course comes out to documentation but
if you don't find a solution don't
hesitate to contact the community we our
mailing list or on Stack Overflow
developers are there as well if you find
any issue just report it that's already
helpful and I have to say that the
simple developer community is I think
very welcoming to to new people and it
really tries to make it easy to start
contributing to see why they are very
nice like development guys at this dis
address and really it's quite quite easy
to get involved if it was if you know
partner and some mathematics then then
you can get involved and now I would
like to say thank all the cultures of
sin PI whose work I was presenting here
and finally I think for your attention
[Applause]
[Applause]
this simplifies why yes I think if you
if you can get matrix coefficients in
rational numbers then then for sure